[Music]
ah the perks of rv life
[Music]
it's late at night you're tired
you spot a desert campground
pull in and set up shop
buttons are pushed to pop out your
pop-outs
[Music]
a once cram disaster zone becomes
livable for a while
and best of all you've blindly stumbled
onto somewhere like red rock canyon
and well it has much to offer and many
ways to soothe your soul
[Music]
welcome to our three goodyear starred
restaurant
[Music]
make a couple ribeyes some mac and
cheese
[Music]
looks like our first real food we've had
it's not a sandwich
david nicholson ladies and gentlemen
hello world director
we've got vegetables mom
this is good
[Music]
re-energized by kraft's top
powderologists in some instant coffee
we make our move toward the city of
mojave one of my favorite places in the
world
it's the home to the great windmill
forests
[Music]
to neighborhoods full of hard-working
and possibly hard-living
people and most notably
to aerospace adventurers of all stripes
for decades the mojave air and spaceport
has been the place where you test out
weird new crafts
either supersonic jets or space planes
the folks i want to see are as mojave as
it gets
and they have set their sights on the
moon
we're off to see mast in space which i
guess you could consider
a startup in the new space industry
except they've been here
at the mojave airport for about 15 or 16
years
it's a fascinating company
[Music]
mast in space was founded in 2004 by
this guy
dave maston it is said that he is shy or
elusive
or both so here i am with this guy
sean mahoney the longtime ceo of mastin
this is where madison started yeah this
was the
original building we've reconfigured
things but
um it was a garage rocket
company literally in the garage
very hands-on gritty get it done
rather than the you know white lab coat
kind of thing
[Music]
over the years mastin has built up a
reputation
as a great place for young hungry
engineers to get their hands dirty with
aerospace technology
we're talking small teams of five or six
people
building things like this
[Music]
that's zombie it's not the prettiest
spacecraft
but it proved that you could take off
vertically cut the engine
re-light it and land
this all happened back in 2010 well
before spacex was landing rockets
and it caught the attention of one elon
musk
that is a phenomenal email and it's
glad to have helped inspire
now today mastin has got
over 600 flight operations under our
belt with
these type vehicles no one else
has done 600 rocket landing operations
period what sean will not say is this
for years maston has lived hand to mouth
going from one small contract to another
it hasn't been the best run or frankly
most viable business
in fact mastin kind of became known for
getting passed by by the likes of spacex
rocket lab and others
which is why it was quite the surprise
when nasa decided to give this tiny
outfit
80 million dollars this year to build a
lunar lander
mastin has a series of instruments
that nasa has selected that we are going
to deliver to the south pole of the moon
in december
of 2022 that's that's soon that is soon
and so after a decade of building blocks
and iterations
it's now go time
we're purchasing the ride to
point us at the moon so inside of a
spacex
yeah and then our craft will do the
corrections
bring us in put us on the surface and i
think it's going to fly nine scientific
apparatus is that right we've got
instruments that are going to be
trying to scan the surface of the moon
from on the lander itself
but being able to execute that landing
is
going to be the tricky part and we've
got a couple different landing sites
that we're still kind of looking at
despite the massive contract mastin's
digs are as humble as ever
and it's grit still very gritty are
these guys getting ready for something
this is a small rocket engine test rig
okay
this is where we learn and practice and
get that real world experience that's
not the stuff that's in the textbook
one of the beautiful things about
operating in mojave
we have a test site on the other end of
the airport you hook it up
you drive it out you do the test
there's no getting on the plane there's
no shipping
it's right here
part of the story of mastin and being
out here and and being this
um hands-on place is like things aren't
things weren't always
great right because you're you're
dependent on a contract here and there
and so what's it been like keeping the
business running
all this time it's been a challenge um
we will look at a project we'll do an
estimate and we'll say great we'll do it
for this amount
so when things go over it's on us
the market while there is commercial
customers
the reality is there's still government
dollars that are really the major driver
now with nasa kind of as the anchor
customer for some of these missions
there's a market that's established and
in a
broader sense these next five years
are going to set the standards
for humanity's expansion beyond the
planet
we will return american astronauts to
the moon for the first time since
1972 for long-term exploration and use
the current administration is super into
the moon and
i mean for you guys this has all been
pretty fortuitous yeah
look the moon is a topic of
international
discussion and debates eventually
human beings will draw the moon into our
economic sphere of influence
that is where humanity will be
and so the ones who get there to
establish the services whether it's
communication
whether it's transportation interfaces
or
any of these things the people who are
doing it will get the chance to set
those things
now well i see elon's elon's now that
there's
money out there he's suddenly interested
in the mood as well so yeah
so and that's been it is really cool to
see
the thing that you've been working on
become popular but
really elon is very focused on mars
let's go to the moon first you didn't
say anything about the shirt man
i um noticed immediately and i greatly
appreciate it um
is the is the lander like sitting in a
one of these warehouses
or like what stage are we so we do have
some hardware that's already
coming in probably middle of next year
is when you will have an actual thing
together and this will be getting
information from the moon
where artemis is planning to land humans
[Music]
mastin's survival seems assured for now
[Music]
that's not always the case here in
mojave
other space startups like x-core have
gone by the wayside
and companies like virgin have spent
more than 500 million dollars trying to
reach orbit
with little success
the biggest risk takers though are
humans like elliot here
because he's a test pilot who volunteers
to put his life
on the line
the last time i saw elliot was right
after that crash way back in 2016.
he sat for an interview to be the pilot
for that test
they're not skills you can like just go
get even took me flying
there's a couple big bumps out there
today
he never let on that it was his first
time back in a plane after the wreck
or that he was still wounded and uneasy
because i'm a jerk i asked elliot to
take me to the scene of the crash
the famed mojave boneyard where planes
go
to decompose tell me about this crash
you were testing out a plane and i mean
tell me tell me what happened
so this opportunity came out where a
small jet engine company
was looking for somebody to debut their
engine
we flew the airplane successfully two
times and then the third flight we had
an engine failure
and i ended up weaving my way between
the tails of the 747s here in the
boneyard
until i could find a soft spot to put it
down
at the end of the day you know the
engine that failed was a prototype
engine
uh so you know we i knew the risks that
i was getting into
you walked away but you must have been
shaking for a while
after that yeah i mean obviously if
you're if you don't walk out of that and
think
uh about what you're doing with your
life you're actually probably have
problems but um
i was flying again within a few days of
the accident and testing i had another
major incident in an airplane an
emergency landing within a week of that
uh uh that one so so you know get back
up on the horse
have you considered shirtless beach
volleyball
not until this moment
[Laughter]
unlike many test pilots with military
training
elliot is actually an engineer who's had
to work his way up
into the test pilot game there's
basically two paths to flight tests um
one is uh you go be a fighter pilot then
you go from fighter pilot to test pilot
the other is you go spend 10 15 years
with a small company and you work your
way from like an engineer
to make that jump to the left seat i was
i still if it's about your story man i
mean so you've got you've got the guys
you see in top gun
and that's kind of who you're competing
against somebody's got a new plane
and then you got to go up against the
top gun guy and explain to these people
why you should
fly the plane yeah fundamentally
remember we lost a program to an
astronaut i never even like made a
counterpoint right
but now that i've been in this business
for a while like the science as an
engineer is fascinating
right like you go and learn something in
school you can read it in a book you can
see how the equation works but until you
can like feel it in your hand and see
how that all adds up to
whether it is or is not what you want
from an airplane that's a whole other
level
and as a test pilot i've flown 80
different kinds of airplanes
successfully
i've got 11 first flights so that means
you're like the first person to take the
machine up yeah
mojave's had this mythic status you know
of
this is where you come to do the most
groundbreaking work and
to push machines to their edge i mean is
that is that still the case
i think there's no question that mojave
is absolutely on the radar right now i
mean there's
the whole world's watching to see what
comes out of mojave this is very
desolate land where you can play and do
things you can't do other places on the
planet
and it attracts like big ego dudes like
you know
frontal lobe kind of guys and to be able
to get a bunch of smart dudes pointing
the same direction go
make something fly that doesn't look
like it should that's a hard thing and
it's
very rewarding when it works and when it
doesn't you can spend an eternity
thinking about all how it all added up
against you
and so here we are in 2020
a pandemic fires in the west
the overall madness of a year which
feels more and more like a work
of experimental dadia start
and yet somehow i end up in the back of
a pickup truck
driving through a plane graveyard during
a mojave sunset
it's not perfect because perfect can't
exist right now
but i gotta tell you it ain't bad
so the last segment of your trip down
395 takes us to mojave
which it sounds like you've been to
before as an aerospace
reporter and enthusiast this seems like
a place that you would probably want to
go to
often um what made you decide to go back
you were like were you just like it's
along the route this makes sense for the
show
something new was happening like what
brought you there yeah well part of it
was
gives you that extreme of being in the
desert and kind of like at the
ground floor after we'd been up in the
mountains and some of the other
episodes and then you were very polite
but the other part is just that i'm a
total aerospace nerd
um helplessly i mean in particular i
love the master story because you
talk about how hard it is to make it
actually be a business like there's
there's it feels like there's this
tension between
like building the cool thing that shoots
off into the air
and trying to make sense of something or
like can you just talk more about that i
wanted to know like why
do you think they didn't why do you
think they have had such a hard scrabble
15 years and why has it been hard for
them to have the same
excused upon liftoff as other as
other space companies yeah madison's
fascinating because they're in like this
weird time and place where like the
the founder he'd gotten rich in silicon
valley but not like
elon or jeff bezos rich and they they
came along like 15 years ago so it was
like that was back when
most of the new space stuff was kind of
failing and spacex was like just start
they were in this weird time and they've
always been so every
rocket company i run to like spacex or
blue origin all the big ones half the
people you meet they're not half but a
bunch of the people you meet there
you're just like oh where'd you work
before i was like oh i was i was a
college dropout and i went to maston and
i worked there for two years it's like
this this training ground
and and most so many of the cool people
i've met in the aerospace industry came
from mastin and i was like i gotta go
see this place i've been trying to get
there for a while they usually they they
sort of like were kind of like
anti-attention
um and until i think they i think this
moon contract they're a little
more willing to talk now but yeah so
i've always wanted to to see the place
just because it has this
totally unique position in the aerospace
world is like i don't want to say minor
leagues but it's like the
the training ground for for like the big
aerospace companies
was the moon first shirt like is that
like an anti-occupy mars or
like what's the it seemed like that was
the reference but i wasn't sure
it is i am i am neither pro mars or like
antsy or moon but i knew
i knew that would play well at mastodon
uh you know and there is it is funny
because like mars
because like elon and jeff were putting
a lot of attention on it for a while
um the moon had like people were passing
it by
and it wasn't it wasn't getting as much
love and attention and then lately
partly because of uh the political
administration in the u.s and china
getting into the moon and everything you
know it's kind of come back and so yeah
there is
i i don't really affiliate my i think
it's all kind of cool but there is like
this whole
moon first camp which are like screw
mars let's go do this thing and like
prove we could do it and
and it makes more sense to go there yeah
you touched on this a little earlier but
it was a question i have which is yeah
like what is it like to live in mohave
like was there
is there a town like what kind of places
because presumably there's like kind of
a
community of people who both live and
work there and it's kind of in the
middle of nowhere
i always kind of maybe because i don't
have to live there and i'm just passing
through
um i just i like i i like how gritty
the town is and how um
it just like sort of fits the like no bs
thing with with the technology i mean i
mean the people you know
i just dig i dig the vibe the companies
are all
like based in these hangars that are
just attached to the airport and the
airport is it has to be the weirdest
airport in the world because there are
like planes
taking off all the time and yet you can
just totally go to the end of the runway
and like blow up
a rocket engine and you just like ask
for like 20 minutes to go try to
light this thing and everybody's like
okay we'll pause for like 20 minutes i
mean
like all through history there's been
these stories of like these huge
smoke clouds covering the whole airport
and then you've got like the
the airport the air airplane graveyard
that's back there
um speaking of the airplane graveyard
let's talk about the crash video
which like
i'm glad you showed it twice because i
would have not ever wanted to see it and
also wanted to see it like 10 times i
went back and rewind i mean
it's terrifying but yeah and especially
that shot at the end where he's lying
there and
um you can see he's like breathing
really fast and his glasses are as few
and i was i don't know i was just blown
away by it
um yeah like what a job
elliott's like we met him four or five
years ago
and just i was just fascinated by this
guy from
from the start um you know he's and then
i
when you watch that footage you're like
man how can you ever do this again
after that's happened he told me like in
that exact footage you're talking about
where he said it was great because it
showed that he never lost consciousness
and this is like a big thing
in the test pilot world is that if you
could crash
and not go unconscious that that's like
um
that sort of keeps you in a job and it's
i don't know if it's like a badge of
honor but it's like it's like oh okay
this guy he's got what it takes and his
body is cut out for this and so he
he was like oh we're really thankful we
had that that
footage but the first time i saw that
and i knew he'd survive because i'm
still talking to him but like you're
like there's no way this guy walks
out of this plane well it's not like the
planes are designed for
like ultra safety i mean it's like they
tend to be tiny or
like the it's either focused on
something else they're not like race
cars where there's like you know you see
those guys have horrendous
wrecks but then like every they're in
this cocoon of protection i mean
it's it's like not like that at all and
then you know he says that he says
you know he's like i i found somewhere
soft to take it in i mean it's like
it's a it's a trailer full he said it
was like full of like all this old nasa
um phone books i think or something like
that so
that was like the the softest place and
then he was he was talking a little bit
about um i think like on reddit and some
other spots you know there's all these
other
um either armchair pilots or test pilots
giving him grief for like why didn't you
do it this way
why did you do it that way and you know
he was just saying that
um you know when he looked around i mean
everywhere else it was like you were
gonna go into a plane
or some stack of steel
and machinery and so that was like the
best option but i just love
that he called it like a soft spot
yeah that's just not not only like an
incredible story
of a person in an incredible moment but
also of a job that i
just didn't even consider existed but
obviously
thanks for a chat with us it was totally
really fun
and kind of different to do and uh and i
definitely
came to appreciate rvs and
and getting out and it's like i would i
would 100
do it again
[Music]
you